embattled Harvard president Claudine gay
has finally resigned after a bruising
Congressional testimony in which she
defended calls to genocide the Jews and
amid the discovery of consistent
plagiarism throughout her conspicuously
small Corpus of scholarly Publications
to announce her resignation president
gay stated quote fans for the past two
weeks you've been reading about the bad
break I got yet today I consider myself
the luckiest man on the face of the
earth I have been inol parks for 17
years and have never received anything
but kindness and encouragement from you
fans sure I'm lucky when the New York
Giants a team you would give your right
arm to beat and vice versa sends you a
gift that's something so I close in
saying that I may have had a tough break
but I have an awful lot to live
for it was an unusual resignation but
everyone Grieves in his or her own way I
guess the Harvard liberals who appointed
her despite her utter lack of
qualification ations are grieving
themselves when gay was named just 6
months ago this is the shortest tenure
of any Harvard president ever Harvard
magazine hailed her as a Scholars
scholar which is technically true since
her scholarship is mostly that of other
Scholars the liberal media for their
part are not going down easy with one
CNN reporter reacting to the news by
attempting to redefine the word
plagiarism these plagiarism allegations
uh where Claud and gay has had to issue
Corrections um multiple Corrections now
we should note that um claudon gay has
not been accused of stealing anyone's
ideas in any of her writings uh she's
been accused of sort of more like
copying uh other people's writings
without attribution so it's been more
sloppy attribution than stealing
anyone's ideas it's not she she didn't
steal their ideas she stole their words
that expressed their ideas and but it's
so it's not it's more it's not
like uh it's not like plagiarism it's
like uh it's like you're it's like she
plagiarized something but not not quite
convincing former president gay for her
part is signing off in exactly the way
that you would expect by playing the
race card and blaming her outing on the
quote racial animus of bigoted whites A
fitting way to go for a woman who only
got the job by hustling her race in the
first place see you later I'm Michael
nolles this is the Michael nolles
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the show a lady is
accusing a teenage McDonald's Clerk of
uh Shilling for the vast Jewish
conspiracy through through chicken
McNuggets wrapping we'll get to that in
just a moment first though I don't want
to move on too quickly from the Claudine
gay
story this was a big deal probably the
most prominent figure front-facing
figure in outing Claudine gay is Chris
rufo friend of mine uh Think Tank
scholar author of a terrific new book
and the the man who made critical race
Theory a household term the man who just
keeps collecting leftwing scalps this
time he can claim the scalp of the
Harvard president how did he do it how
did he do
it he was very clever that's how it's
not easy to do this sort of thing but
one thing I Love About Chris is that he
uh constantly tells you what he's doing
so he he not only achieves the political
operation but he explains how he's doing
it while he does it Claudine gay did not
get ousted over plagiarism
if it was this were just plagiarism she
would still be in her
position she got ousted because she
defended the right of students to call
for the genocide of the Jews during
Congressional testimony that's what got
usted that's what got the pen lady
ousted when she said the exact same
thing at the exact same Congressional
testimony she was ousted immediately
because she's a white lady Claudine gay
got to hang on cuz she's a black lady
and she can claim more victim status and
it would have been Politically Incorrect
to fire her at least
immediately the plagiarism was just an
excuse to fire her she still gets to
keep her her job at Harvard not the
president job but the faculty job she
will still be teaching students every
student in her class by the way should
openly plagiarize every one of the
papers for her class what's that woman
going to say what's Harvard going to do
they're going to punish the students for
doing exactly what the professor did so
so this woman gets a soft Landing it's
not about plagiarism If This Were about
plagiarism Kevin Cruz who is the lib's
favorite histor Oran at Princeton he's a
professor at Princeton but he spends
most of his time going on leftwing TV
shows to attack conservatives that guy
would have been gone a long time ago
because that guy was quite credibly
accused of plagiarism and then plagiar
Princeton rather did the exact same
thing Harvard did they had some little
internal investigation they dismissed
all the findings because Kevin Cruz is
popular among the political left just as
they did with with Claudine gay before
they fired her so it's not about
plagiarism it's about her weakness she
was already extremely weakened by the
charges of anti-Semitism and that is
when Chris rufo and the conservatives
pounced this is actually an example of
the lib's favorite headline
conservatives pounce they did pounce now
they pounced in a totally just and
appropriate way here This Woman's entire
academic career is a joke first of all
she had 11 scholarly
Publications a real scholar will have 11
Publications by by the time they're in
grad school okay this woman had 11
scholarly Publications total by the time
she was president of the supposedly most
prestigious College in the country so
her academic career is a complete joke
she teaches in a fake Department called
African-American studies which is one of
these critical theory derived AC pseudo
academic disciplines to just
indoctrinate people in leftism without
even much pretense as to to uh
cultivating in them serious uh liberal
arts and scholarship so she had that
then turns out she stole a bunch of of
her work and Chris and other right wiers
pounced there by the way I I forget the
journalist's name very good journalist
who had covered the Claudine gay
plagiarism Scandal years ago didn't go
anywhere it was never going to go
anywhere until Claudine gay was weakened
and the easiest way to weaken her right
now was through the anti-Semitism charge
so weekend Chris rufo rallies the right
the right gets on board okay we're going
to oust Claudine gay the president of
Harvard we're going to claim a top
academic scalp then this is the next
important thing Chris did he smuggled
the ideas into the left and he said he
was doing this he said we've already
done what we can for the conservative
side now we got to smuggle this idea
that we need to oust gay into the left
which he did through a New York Times
uped written by I think Josh McCarter
starting to get some of the left Wingers
to to turn on on the Harvard president
some of the Harvard donors were turning
on the Harvard president and then he
claimed the scalp the reason I mention
all of this is because there's a really
important lesson here conservatives have
spent a long time insulting and
attacking and enying against the
prominent leftist intellectuals of the
last century if you open up I would say
seven out of 10 right-wing pical books
you're going to read about Antonio gromi
the the leftist Italian philosopher
you're going to read about Herbert
maruza the the father of the new Left
you're going to read about the Frankford
school you're going to read about
Theodor dorno you're going to read about
maybe uh uh Rudy duka may maybe you're
going to read about all of these guys
even solinsky right you're going to read
about them and the smart conservatives
read gromi and maruza to attack them but
the smarter conservatives read gromi and
maruza to take notes to to observe
success ful political tactics and then
to figure out how to emulate those
tactics without doing anything immoral
without doing anything unjust without
doing anything for evil ends but to
apply those same procedures and
tactics through moral means for good
ends that's what rufo's done here it's a
major major win and we got to talk about
it when you want to talk to your friends
you got to check out P talk right now go
to PE talk.com the holidays have come
and gone and you were very generous well
don't worry Pure Talk has your back
instead of paying your current cell
phone provider 60 70 80 bucks a line
Pure Talk has unlimited plans starting
at just $20 a month you will get the
same phenomenal coverage that you're
used to on America's Most Dependable 5G
Network for a great price this is how
the average family saves almost $1,000 a
year it is time to switch to a wireless
company that shares your values a
company that is veteran-owned and
invests in the daily wire so what are
you waiting for switch to Pure Talk in
as little as 10 minutes start saving
today their Us customer service team is
waiting to serve you go to Pur talk.com
right now you'll save an additional 50%
off your first month that is p
talk.com to be connected now peer
talk.com to start off the year saving on
wireless with a company that you can be
proud of Pur
talk.com can
Wes head on over there right now
speaking of leftwing Institutions going
down Mickey Mouse has entered the public
domain sort of what does this mean means
that Mickey Mouse is very very old the
earliest version of Mickey Mouse comes
from a cartoon called Steamboat
Willie and this dates back to the
1920s so initially the copyright
protection for Mickey Mouse for this
type of media was going to run out after
70 years and then Sunny Bono a Hollywood
guy who became a member of Congress he
he up updated the copyright protections
I think it was called the the Mickey
Mouse protection act or save Mickey
Mouse Act is how it was colloquially
referred to because Disney was about to
lose its hold on its most popular
character so Disney lobbied really
really hard and they were able to extend
this so that they had protections for 95
years well the 95 years are up so the
earliest version of Mickey Mouse is now
public domain which means that anybody
can do it which means you know you know
the minute Jeremy heard about this a
thousand ideas started popping off in
his head and I haven't even talked to
Jeremy about that I just know it I know
it intuitively well apparently that was
true for other people because Mickey
Mouse is now going to appear in non-
Disney Productions including this horror
movie yeah he's like completely in love
with me already it's totally
disgusting put the phone down put the
phone down please I was like do already
J turn it around please
J Cy right
back and he's dead what
like if he was in a horror movie you'd
never say I'll be right back cuz then
you
[Applause]
don't where the hell did he go
Mickey's Mouse
Trap apparently there are multiple
versions of this of Mickey Mouse horror
movies now similar to Winnie the Pooh
Blood and Honey when Winnie the Pooh
became a public domain character so it's
all very
funny however it's not
enough Mickey Mouse has to become a Nazi
he has
to because Disney is a very very evil
corporation that wants
to and fill their heads with all sorts
of crazy ideas and Disney's Disney's got
to go Disney's got to go guys you you
heard all the Disney Executives talking
about their not so secret LGBT element
op agenda you you've seen what what
Disney has done in recent years so much
so that the governor of Florida had to
take political action against them to
stop Disney from trying to interfere in
the Democratic process in Florida to
stop the Libs from okay Disney is really
really bad and so one of the best things
that we can do right now is make the
Disney characters toxic and
coincidentally Call It providentially
Whatever It Is the Disney character is
now in the public
domain and what this means
is we need to turn Mickey into a Nazi
because Nazis are are bad we we're not
going to turn Mickey into a Nazi because
the Nazis are good you see I'm quite
anti-nazi I assume you are as well in
fact being a Nazi is the worst thing you
can possibly be today and for a very
long time so we need to turn Disney into
the worst thing it can possibly be and
it can be done in fact I'm shocked that
the mischievous people on places like
forchan and other internet boards
haven't done this already remember what
they did to that cartoon frog there was
that cartoon frog this was many years
ago I'm dating myself to to think back
on the hon years of 2016 2016 which was
eight years ago by the way in my mind
2016 was like two years ago it was eight
years ago but anyway back in those days
there was this cartoon frog that a
regular cartoonist had made and it was
kind of a popular web comic and then
these guys on forchan turned the Frog
into a Nazi and since then the frog has
actually I think come out of his Nazi
phase I it's very difficult to track
memes cuz it's it's memetic right it
just kind of it moves through imitation
and it's it's really hard to get your
hands on but for a while the Frog was a
Nazi and it drove the cartoonist who
made the Frog completely crazy because
the Frog became a hate symbol it was
listed on all splc ADL all these
different lists and we can do the same
with Mickey Mouse it's not just enough
to make Mickey Mouse a serial killer as
you're seeing in these movies Mickey
Mouse has to become the most odious kind
of symbol in the entire world and we
have the ability to do it not using any
major institutional power just through
the power of memes by pseudonymous
accounts on random internet boards
that's what's got to happen because
Disney's bad Disney's got to go down now
speaking of the
media this is a weird one this is a
weird
story bear with me here this is a story
from the Florida GOP chairman Christian
zegler
who is now being investigated by the
police for video
voyerism and this guy I don't know this
guy
but Christian zegler is a married guy
and he and his wife apparently have had
some
minaa with some other lady now the other
lady is claiming to be a victim of
rape and in in this case in particular
video voyerism
at the hands of Christian Zigler so this
guy's wife admitted to detectives that
she knew the the alleged victim here
through her husband and having a
confirmed sexual encounter with this
woman and her husband a year ago but
said it only happened one time now
apparently Mr Ziegler and the other lady
wanted it to happen again so he was
texting this girl and uh they had made
plans and then at the last minute he
said okay it's just going to be me by
the
way classic trick right I I assume and
and so he says yeah anyway our our
manaja it's actually going to be a
manaja du because my wife isn't going to
come so we're still good and the woman
said no she said sorry I was mostly in
for her so she said she says no we're
not going to do it so then zegler is
accused of going to the woman's
apartment and doing the deed with
her later the woman said that she was
raped and the reason she said she was
raped is because she said she couldn't
have consented to the sex and she says
she couldn't have consented because she
had been drinking all day so it's sort
of unclear what exactly transpired in
the apartment but the claim of not
having given consent comes according to
the woman from the fact that she was
super drunk in her
apartment she later told Zigler this and
said uh that she she wasn't okay with
what happened and zler responded
according to text messages oh that's not
good you are my friend known you for
like 20 years now L and she says yeah I
know but that was not cool and you
didn't bring her and then did that to me
and then zegler responded she was
in uh she said she's in oh she was in
then couldn't because no response she
said in next time but I understand
okay so this colors the image a little
bit I guess of what transpired but
that's not even what's being
investigated here what's being
investigated here is video voyerism
because apparently the time that they
did have the
minajatwa
uh the guy videotaped it and I guess is
presenting this as some kind of evidence
for the uh consensual nature of their
encounters and but then the woman and
the guy
say no we didn't consent to being
videotaped and so now you got this
charge of video voyerism what is video
voyerism well according to Florida law
video voyerism is a third deegree felony
could bring a punishment of up to five
years behind bars uh you violate the law
if you secretly record another person
for your own quote own Amusement
entertainment sexual arousal
gratification or profit or for the
purpose of degrading or abusing another
person in a circumstance where the
victim quote has a reasonable
expectation of privacy now here's the
key if you are sleeping with someone do
you have a reasonable expectation of
privacy if you're having a Manas so
there's another person involved do you
have a reasonable expectation of
privacy
no all of this behavior is obviously
extremely degenerate I would have no
problem with people passing laws against
all of it okay it's fine by me I'm not
in any way defending any of this
Behavior but I
am simply
befuddled at the notion that one would
have a reasonable expectation of privacy
when having a threesome with a bunch of
randos that's just totally crazy and and
I guess the deeper part of this to me
what this is all about to me and it
seems clear as day this is all about
porn why are these why is this couple
having this weird sexual affair
I I would bet the farm that they're
really into porn in fact the way I know
that they're really into porn or at
least that the guy's really into porn
he's making a porno that's what's so
crazy about these encounters and a lot
of these uh sexual cases that are
cropping up today a lot of it involves
media a lot of it involves video and
photographs which is so much creepier
you can't even just go out and have your
sort of degenerate romp you've got to
record it so that so you can use it as
pornography later this is a perfect
example of the pornification of culture
seeping into everything and turning
people's brains to Mush and confounding
the law because it it blurs all sorts of
lines uh that really ought not to be
blurred so what's the answer to
this cut it off at the source one of the
big drivers of lust one of the big
drivers of these new legal technolog
iCal problems one of the one of the just
the creepiest aspects of the whole thing
this is a pretty creepy situation to
begin with but but the creepiest aspect
is the camera cut it out something we
should all pray for and when you want to
pray one great tool to help you pray is
hallow right now go to hall.com what
better New Year's resolution than
building a daily habit of prayer and
meditation prayer can help you cultivate
an attitude of gratitude hallow is the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
United States it has helped many
maintain a daily prayer routine it can
help you too download hallow right now
at hall.com
you can set prayer reminders and track
your progress along the way are you not
sure where to start we'll check out
father Mike schmitz's Bible in a year or
as I call it Bible in four years but I
keep chugging along and it's an
excellent podcast probably my very
favorite one it's available on the
Hallow app you get brief daily readings
and Reflections you can join Mark
Wahlberg Jim cavel even some worldclass
athletes with hallow you can customize
personal prayer plan and listen wherever
you are with downloadable offline
sessions you need to have a relationship
with God and you need to be a better
person and you need to be holy and the
only way to do that is to pray so you
need to start praying right now download
hallow at hall.com canw Lees get an
exclusive thre months free that is three
months absolutely free at hall.com slns
can
wle speaking of the
media an equally disturbing story but
not nearly as weird uh Poland has has a
new liberal government and the new
liberal government is Banning the
conservative media they're they're
dissolving the state
media which is not you know public media
when when we
describe the media of countries we don't
like we call it statun media but then
when we describe our own state-run media
we use nicer terms it's public media
it's National Public Radio we love
National oh it's PBS the libs that's
their favorite thing PBS NPR oh it's
wonderful even the media organs that are
not technically owned by the state but
which simply spread the propaganda for
the state I think of the Washington Post
New York Times oh that's different but
they have in North Korea that's
state-run media what we have here oh
it's just public-minded public
interested sometimes public funded media
that's totally different okay well the
libs are thrilled about
this this is Reuters a media company you
know the journalist the fourth State
they say polish government takes public
TV News Channel off air a mid reform
Drive mid reform
if Orban in Hungary did this what would
you hear the authoritarian right-wing
dictator of Hungary is suppressing the
Free Press the great journalists of the
fourth estate this is the end of
democracy and but what happens when
Poland does a far more egregious version
of anything that Orban has ever done
that Orban has ever done I miss pronoun
his name sometimes what happens oh it's
it's a reform
Drive War saw December 20th Poland's new
government took a public News Channel
off the air on on Wednesday and
dismissed Executives from State media to
restore impartiality the culture
Ministry said as prime minister Donald
tusk's reform Drive faced its first big
test tusk's pro-european government
Coalition a European Union Coalition
took power last week from the
nationalist Law And Justice party which
critics say damaged judicial
Independence soured European Union
relations and turned state-owned media
into an outlet for propaganda during its
eight years in office and now this great
hero of democracy and freedom he's
Banning the
Press I think we got a lump Reuters in
under the state media here that's an
amazing degree of spin but it's a
reminder that there's no
neutrality there's no neutrality here in
the Press there never was for all of
American history for all of the history
of Journalism and then after World War
II during the post-war liberal consensus
we convinced ourselves that there was
neutrality there wasn't for goodness
sakes Walter kronite the most trusted
man in news the man was a world
Federalist okay he was a huge lib at
best but no he was impartial we had all
these impartial journalists we didn't
they were just Libs who were good at
hiding their tracks much like Reuters I
mean the the most amazing part of this
whole story is not that the leftists in
Poland are are suppressing all the
conservatives and you know dismantling
democracy and whatever the most
surprising part of the story is that
Reuters can publish this ridiculous
propaganda with a straight face like
just I after the show I'm GNA have to
Google Reuters
orbon media to see the hysterical
headlines which I saw throughout the
leftwing Press but Poland does a more
egregious version of the same thing
thing it's wonderful of course because
it's not just procedure that matters
okay it's not just form that matters
it's substance too the substance what
are we actually doing that matters a lot
not a good look for Reuters or for
Poland now speaking of how people look
there's a new report out that Zoomers
whom I love you know I'm very Pro Zoomer
in the battle between Zoomer
conservatism and Boomer conservatism I'm
with the Zoomers they're far more
traditional they're more interested in
virtue and Order more interested in
substantive Goods I'm I love the Zoomers
so this criticism of the Zoomers is
coming from a place of
love there's a report out that gen Z is
aging differently from
Millennials Millennials look weirdly
young maybe not me because my diet
consists of uh espresso black tea
whiskey and tobacco so I don't maybe I
haven't aged quite as as gracefully but
Millennials are aging really really
gracefully y generally they look younger
at our at our respective ages than Gen X
did than the Boomers did and then
Zoomers do why is that experts are
blaming this
on skincare routines and cosmetic
procedures so according to this is a
report from I think the Daily Mail
Millennials look relatively younger
healthier diets better knowledge of
skincare and Improvement in makeup means
those born between 1980 and 1997 appear
more youthful than older Generations did
at the same
age overuse or unnecessary application
of filler and toxins at a young age may
affect the natural facial development
causing younger patients to look older
than they are this is according to
celebrity Cosmetics doctor Rasha
rakshani Madam told this to
female which is I don't know some outlet
but it's a it's a pun you get it f m a i
l
female I bring up the story at all
because I it's an unpopular but it's an
urgent
take cosmetic
procedures in almost all circumstances
make people look worse and many many
people are getting them a lot of Zoomers
are getting them very very young people
are getting these cosmetic procedures
and they almost always make you look
worse I'm thinking especially of the
increasingly popular lip fillers which a
lot of people are getting look if you've
gotten them I'm not saying it's the end
of the world but cut it out they look
bad they always look bad and especially
Botox Botox
Botox botulinum toxin is the most toxic
naturally occurring substance known to
man it is a military-grade biological
weapon and the moment people hear this
they're stand they're standing around
you know they see news reporters say
botulinum toxin the most
poisonous toxic substance ever
discovered by oh great can you inject it
into my face please so that I don't look
my age that would be great wouldn't it
seems like a pretty bad
idea don't do it it looks bad even even
the little things oh but botulinium
toxin by the way for those don't know
who that is that's Botox it's just it's
the most popular cosmetic treatment in
the world don't stop
it 24% of Americans have had these
treatments if you've had it
okay it's fine we all make mistakes I've
made plenty of mistakes just cut it out
for your own sake for how you will look
cut it out you don't need it you're very
pretty on your own you're you're and
you're relatively much prettier than you
will be if you have all these
mutilations speaking of toxic
substances there's a lady who is
alleging that McDonald's has changed its
rappers to support the state of Israel
so I was starving so I had to get one
quick sandwich from here and I thought
they gave me the wrong sandwich but
conveniently McDonald's changed their
packaging wow what does that
resemble yeah so what is this this one
yeah what is this new packaging it's the
make chicken WRA it but why is it blue
and white I honestly I don't know I
think you do know this is in support of
Israel they Chang I mean it was like
that actually since a few months ago
because we ran out the regular ones no I
I don't think so this is obviously in
support of Israel no I mean we actually
had that for a while though I was here 2
weeks ago and it wasn't like this I mean
we have had We R one I I know this is
not your fault cuz you're an employee
but I think this is disgusting for them
to do this and I know you in your heart
you know in your heart that this is
clearly what this rapper is for but I
mean I didn't know that though I'm I'm
explaining it to you it is this is what
it's for this is the color of their flag
this is clearly what they're doing and
what they're showing going to people and
I think it's disgusting it's clear you
know just like this morning when I got
out of bed and I stubb my toe and I knew
it was the Jews I knew it why are you
looking at me like that g not take
Flamingo what's this jacket you're
putting on me what are you talking
about these guys I had not seen that
clip I just read about it it it lived up
to its reputation um I don't think I
don't call me call me naive but I I
don't think that the McDonald's chicken
sandwich
rapper is a subliminal message to
convince the the goyam to support the
state of Israel I don't I don't look I
don't maybe maybe I just haven't
discovered that that dark corner of the
internet yet where I see The Smoking Gun
but I don't really see it and these
people need
help these people the kind of people who
stubb the their toe in the morning and
blame the
Jews they're the same forget the Jews
for a second it's the same kind of
people who stub their toe in the morning
and blame the CIA or the people who stub
their toe in the morning and blame the
Illuminati or the people who stub their
toe in the morning who blame this that
or the other
thing and the problem with it Andrew
claven says this all the time it's not
it's not that bigots are wrong about the
other guy it's that they're wrong about
themselves and they're wrong about the
way that the world works
okay if you search for simplistic
answers to political
problems you're you're one you're going
to be wrong and you're going to think
that you know the chicken sandwich is is
a Jewish conspiracy but two you're going
to seed the whole political
order if if you believe that every issue
in the country is is the CIA or
something not only are you going to look
ridiculous you're not going to fix any
problems because it's not just the CIA
and it's not just the FBI and it's not
just the NS a and it's not just the this
NGO and it's not just this left-wing
Mega donor and it's not just this
political systems are extraordinarily
complex
and to to blame it you know in this case
she's blaming it on the Jews it's not
only sort of unjust but it's just
ridiculous and it paralyzes people it
paralyzes people from actually
addressing any of the problems around
them now turning to actual Israel
related issues Beyond uh chicken
sandwiches and and obviously not Kosher
sandwiches it occurs to me the Double
Quarter Pounder with cheese that's not
Kosher how would the Jews be behind that
well that maybe that's why they're
behind the chicken sandwich I don't know
I don't know I haven't talked to that
lady there was a call that just came out
by some Israeli ministers to resettle
the Gaza population so an explicit call
for the displacement of of Gins this is
from national security minister itamar
Ben
gavier uh and another one what's the
other one uh uh Israeli Minister bezel
smotri uh AR arguing
for the uh migration of the residents of
Gaza Ben gavier says this is quote an
opportunity to concentrate on
encouraging the migration of the
residents of Gaza and the the other
ministers said the same thing the Biden
Administration has shot this idea down
US state department has has called out
these two ministers for quote
inflammatory and irresponsible rhetoric
and I agree I think it's it's
inflammatory it's irresponsible I get
why they're doing it if I were an
Israeli Minister I'd be calling for the
same thing I'd be saying look we can't
tolerate Gaza to exist as a political
unit anymore we can't tolerate these
people here it's too much of a security
risk and we got to we got to ethnically
cleanse the area probably that's what I
would be say if I were an Israeli
Minister I would probably be saying the
exact same thing that these guys are but
it's just not going to fly and here's
why it's not going to fly it's not that
it's not going to fly because of public
opinion public opinion in America is
still broadly in favor of Israel public
opinion in America even with the
claudian gays of the world and the aoc's
of the world is still broadly opposed to
Hamas and Hezbollah and all these
jihadis the reason it's not going to
fly is there's nowhere to resettle them
to where do you want to resettle one
it's kind of an ugly thing to move whole
populations from their territories that
they live in but but two where you going
to put them none of the Arab states want
them none of the Arab states will take
them in one because it creates political
pressure against the state of Israel to
keep them there and two because they
they just don't want them they think
it's a security risk so the Arab states
aren't going to take them Israel's
obviously not going to take them the
whole reason they're saying they got to
move them is because they're too much of
a security risk to even have on the
Southwest part of the
country so who going to is is Europe
going to take them that's that has been
the answer for a lot of migration amid
wars in the Middle East I don't think
Europe wants that I think this is the
biggest issue right now in the west the
biggest popular issue if people still
have any say in their government the
biggest popular issue is mass migration
which is causing all sorts of cascading
social effects so I don't
think if the people still have any say
in their government in Europe Europe's
not the answer is America the answer do
we want to take in the Palestinian
refugees I don't think so I I don't
think that's a good idea if if the state
of Israel is saying that these people
are too dangerous to have on our border
well then they're too dangerous to have
in our country of
course so the the natural answer that if
you are going to move an entire
population of people that has come is
okay the neighboring Arab states should
take them in but the neighboring Arab
states don't want to do it so there's
just no solution which is why I've said
from the beginning of this conflict the
massive pgr the Massive Attack by Hamas
on Israel and then the war that has
continued to
escalate it's an ract problem there's
really no simplistic solution to it so
what is the American interest the
American interest is to contain the war
and certainly not to take in a whole
population of people that everyone on
Earth agrees are
extremely dangerous can't do it it pity
as we might feel for them it's just
crazy especially at a time when Mass
migration is the big issue in our
civilization so what are we going to do
about it well there is something that
the US is doing in the war in the Middle
East that I think is perfectly fine but
we'll get to one second first here at
the dailywire we're taking back the
culture we've got some incredible things
lined up for you this year like the
hilarious Mr burum coming early 2024
featuring Adam Corolla Roseanne Bar
Megan Kelly and more plus the highly
anticipated series The Pen Dragon cycle
and the 2024 election will be one of the
most pivotable pivotable it's I I said
that word yesterday too maybe it's going
to become a real word I'm going to make
it's going to be like fetch you know I'm
going to make that a thing it's it's
likely going to be one of the most
pivotal in our nation's history the
election WI is your Source For Truth
bringing you everything from the
campaign trail to the debates and
election day dailywire plus members can
also now unlock our brand new kids at
bent key at no additional cost and of
course you will be the first to see Snow
White and the evil queen featuring Brett
Cooper exclusively on bent key in 2024
your daily wire Plus Membership will
give you more of your favorite podcaster
plus if you're interested some bench buo
Matt Walsh Candace Owens Andrew claven
Jordan Peterson craer youu that's just
the beginning this will be the daily
wire's biggest year ever we need your
support join the fight to reshape and
take back our culture today daily.com
subscribe my favorite comment yesterday
it's from John Schroeder 3172 says the
lady who burned down the abortion clinic
would not have gotten any time in prison
for burning down a church true a true
church like the Church of God of our
Lord Jesus Christ the church that formed
our entire civilization had she burned
down one of those she certainly would
have gotten no prison time she probably
would have gotten a medal
but she burned down a different kind of
church she burned down one of their
churches she burned down one of the
churches for the libs religion which is
death and the destruction of all that is
nice and flourishing about human life
and one of their churches would be an
abortion clinic we have churches where
you go and worship God you know sing
some hymns have the Liturgy the Holy
Eucharist and their churches are where
they where they kill babies so we burn
down one of theirs and that's why
they're reacting with a quasi religious
Zeal now speaking of this war in the
Middle East the war is escalating the US
Navy has just sunk three hooti ships
after these ships attempted to hijack a
commercial ship and I know there was a
reflexive uh don't get involved kind of
attitude that has come up on the right
and I'm broadly sympathetic to it
certainly was broadly sympathetic when
we're talking about the Ukraine war
certainly I'm sympathetic to it when
it's talking about the war in the Holy
Land as a matter of uh escalating it
into a regional conflict but if we're
just talking about sinking a few random
terrorist ships from the country of
Yemen which is mostly a fake country
anyway uh I think we're okay especially
when the ships were attacking a
commercial
vessel the United States for now is the
global hedgemon might not be for very
long China is clearly
Rising India is rising not in terms of
population really not to challenge
America and hemony but there's there are
other powers that are on the rise okay
but for now we're the global hedgemon
and if we don't use that power we're
going to lose that power so we don't
want to use it in a way that is uh given
to Folly and adventurism where we're
just going to squander our resources and
our uh the lives of American servicemen
for nothing or for things that don't
serve the national interest but in this
case sinking a few hoti boats these
random Jihadi
terrorists and killing their Crews and
all these terrorists who are trying to
hijack a commercial vessel this seems
like a perfectly fine use of US military
and hegemonic mind see that's actually
is a good example A lot of the time I'm
saying the United States military should
not intervene if we want to contain the
conflict I don't think we should go bomb
Iran I don't think that we should go
invade Southern Lebanon or what you know
I don't I don't think we should be doing
any of that stuff I don't think we
should get US troops involved in Ukraine
I think we've probably been too involved
already but this would be a pretty good
example I think if you go in sink a few
boats keep the keep the shipping lanes
open that's that's actually a way to
contain the conflict too because if the
if the jihadis are able to shut down
Commerce around the region that is an
escalation of the
war lots of lots of different ways to
skin a cat but it's it it's not even the
the people who don't want to get
involved are are sometimes as simplistic
as the neocons who want to bomb every
country in the Middle East sometimes the
way to deescalate is to withhold
fighting and sometimes the way to de
escalate is to fight in a very precise
way you know there's a time for every
season under Heaven speaking of jihadis
this is a story that got basically no
coverage but it's a horrific story on on
Christmas or the day after Christmas 160
Christians were slaughtered by Islamic
jihadis in Nigeria 160 of them just just
a a total Killing Spree a gleeful
killing spre by these jihadis against
poor Christians who were just trying to
celebrate one of the holiest times of
the year
and no one's talking about
it which is just a reminder of a finding
of I think it was Pew research some
years ago now it remains true today
Christians are the most persecuted
religious group in the world it's not
even close and we don't really talk
about it and if we're going to use
American Military might for the defense
of somewhat more abstract
values I don't think it's exactly
abstract but somewhat more abstract uh
this might be a good example this is
really awful and and if so if we're
going to have solidarity around the
world what the libs want us to do is
have solidarity for the cause of Human
Rights and democracy and liberalism and
all these really abstract modern kind of
ideas but at the very least we might
have some solidarity with Christians
because we're a Christian Nation we're
founded as a Christian Nation we
developed as a Christian Nation and this
is absolutely horrific and in that cause
of solidary the very least we can do is
pray for them and the very least we can
do is cover the story and cover cover
the severe oppression that the Nigerian
Christians are under at the hand of
Nigerian Muslims meanwhile the
atheists are are saying that the biggest
threat to the country is Christianity
Christian extremism this is according to
a website called atheist Revolution
gearing up for
2024 they say atheists and
non-christians should have among the
highest voter turnout of all why because
of how much we stand to lose when
Christian extremists gain power we
should vote like our lives depend on it
because they do this isn't about
upholding abstract principles or doing
the right thing it is about our survival
if we want to have a future we need to
expand our efforts to oppose Christian
extremism to which I say if you don't
like Christian extremism just wait until
you see unchristian extremism because
it's going to be a lot worse and you're
going to be longing for the days of
Christian extremism Christian extremism
built our country and our whole
civilization and it worked out pretty
well for a long time until we gave up
the Christianity part and we got a
little bit more mild and milk toast and
lukewarm in our Christianity and then
extremism of other kinds starts to
develop and that's going to be bad for
everybody here's a little tease for
tomorrow
shocking shocking New Revelations in the
Jeffrey Epstein case and I've said I've
predicted for a long time we're not
going to get any shocking revelations
we're going to get a lot of smoke going
to get a lot of mirrors but we have
shocking New Revelations coming up
we'll get to that tomorrow rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code NS can
and check it for two months fore on all
annual
[Music]
plans